je pense que les chansons de Johnny Cleg
ont plus fait pour la libération de
Nelson Mandela et pour la fin de
l'apartheid que toutes les résolutions
de l'ONU
la dernière fois que vous êtes venu
j'espère que ce fut la dernière il n'en
est rien votre mère Ingrid béton court
42 ans ex-candidate des vers à la
présidentielle en Colombie et toujours
détenu depuis le 23 février 2002 par la
guérilla marxiste des Farcs des forces
armées révolutionnaires de Colombie en
fait la branche armée du Parti
communiste colombien voilà alors
jusqu'au 23 février 2002 votre maman
Ingrid Bettencourt avait mené contre la
pauvreté la corruption et le trafic de
drogue une lutte exemplaire qui ne peut
que susciter notre respect
alors Mélanie ça fait donc trois ans et
demi King Bettencourt est otage des
Farcs quand avez-vous eu des nouvelles
pour la dernière fois
c'était une preuve de vie une cassette
vidéo
mais depuis on a rien on n'a pas de
preuve de vie
quand on interview
Raoul Reyes qui est le numéro de des
phares qui dit toujours que qu'elle est
en bonne santé comme les autres tâches
mais ce n'est pas une preuve de vie mais
oui bien sûr on la sent du ventre
alors Renaud c'est au troisième
anniversaire de sa détention que vous
avez pris contact avec le comité de
soutien à Ingrid Bettencourt vous
regrettez pas d'avoir fait plus tôt
je regrette je culpabilise un peu mais
bon le mois le jour où je l'ai fait il
se trouve que dans le comité Bettencourt
dans le comité de soutien j'étais non
seulement le seul chanteur à être
présent à manifester ma solidarité et
j'étais aussi la seule personnalité des
personnes à part marécalter qui a
participé à quelques actions dans les
rues et dans les sur la parvis des
Droits de l'Homme avec les amis les
membres anonymes des comités de soutien
et la famille Bettencourt donc il est
jamais trop tard et aujourd'hui il y a
d'autres artistes qui ont rejoint ce
combat et de manière à d'autres encore
et j'essaye avec mes petits moyens de
motiver les artistes internationaux qui
ont participé à travers une chanson à
sensibiliser les populations en France
et partout dans le monde pour alors
aujourd'hui vous voudriez que la
mobilisation pour une grille de
Bettencourt soit comparable à celle qui
a eu pour Florence obnat par exemple
c'est à dire une mobilisation
français en Irak je le regrette que ce
soit pas le cas pour les Bettencourt la
prochaine manifestation pour Ingrid
Bettencourt c'est lundi le 24 octobre à
19h au Théâtre du Rond-Point c'est situé
au rond-point des Champs-Élysées et vous
allez chanter la chanson que avec
buccolo vous avez écrit pour elle Bucolo
a fait une musique c'est absolument
magnifique très une espèce digne faisant
un peu penser musicalement
ce qui a été sacré Vanzetti il y a une
vingtaine d'années une chanson très
mélodie très porteuse qui m'aimait mes
mots
mes petits mots en valeur sur son a été
est en train d'être adapté par Johnny
Clegg pour le pour l'Europe et l'Afrique
et la version espagnole par un artiste
argentin qui s'appelle mailingo qui est
formidable et aussitôt on va en faire
fabriquer une centaine exemplaire pour
l'envoyer très vite en Colombie ou des
radios libres la diffuseront en espérant
que les otages entendront ce message de
solidarité de fraternité des artistes et
des citoyens européen voilà Renault dans
la jungle nous t'attendons Ingrid nous
pensons à toi nous ne serons libres que
quand tu le sauras
très bien
les images qui ont été réalisées par un
artiste motivé concerné aussi qui de son
côté dans ses concerts aussi prend à
partir le public pour les appeler à leur
soutien c'est Romane Serda qui a réalisé
ces images ma petite femme que j'aime et
que j'embrasse c'est une si belle
chanson pouvait faire bouger les choses
comme ça
je sais pas à quel point la difficulté
de la famille Bettencourt ou des gens
des comités de soutien ont eu à facilité
ou non d'avoir accès aux médias d'avoir
le micro tendu c'était qu'une chanson
portée par un chanteur connu
arrive sur ce sujet pour que des
demandes d'interview de caméra de
partout du monde entier trois jours
après la première diffusion de cette
chanson chez votre meilleure amie Fogiel
la semaine dernière
j'ai eu une demande d'interview d'une
radio en direct en direct de Bogota et
j'ai pu adresser au peuple colombien et
aux otages que l'on vient peut-être
espérons et Ingrid bien sûr et à Clara
Rojas son ami un message de solidarité
de des citoyens du monde à travers
cette interview et j'espère qu'il y en
aura d'autres voilà j'espère que la
version espagnole touchera toute
l'Amérique du Sud et la version anglaise
le reste de la planète et la version
française
forcément la Suisse la Belgique la
francophonie quoi la France et le Québec
je pense que les chansons de Johnny Cleg
ont plus fait pour la libération de
Nelson Mandela pour la fin de la parthen
que toutes les résolutions de l'ONU et
voilà c'était un petit coup de chapeau
au passage de Johnny Cleg et au combat
alors évidemment
Christian chez nous qui était otage en
Irak avec
Bruno a dit le pire pour un otage c'est
de se sentir oublier donc là grâce à
vous et grâce à tout ce qui est fait
on espère kingrid ne se sentira pas
complètement oublié mais mettre la
pression sur le gouvernement français en
lui demandant de se mobiliser est-ce que
c'est une bonne stratégie est-ce que ça
risque pas de braquer le président RIB
contre nous
la Cour suprême en Colombie a accepté
que Olivier le président colombien
actuel puisse représenter aux prochaines
élections qui ont lieu en Colombie en
mai 2006 il a changé la Constitution
pour ça il faut comprendre que
il a complètement un double langage
quand il a été élu il y a bientôt quatre
ans une première chose qu'il a faite
c'est aller chez ma grand-mère et lui
dire
je ferai tout pour que Ingrid et les
otages reviennent mais depuis il n'a
fait que stopper toutes les initiatives
tous les moments où on pensait qu'enfin
on allait aboutir à quelque chose que
peut-être un dialogue allait s'ouvrir à
chaque moment il a tout fait pour pour
empêcher que quelque chose se produise
donc donc il faut comprendre que il faut
mettre de la pression sur le
gouvernement que l'on vient ici et
maintenant qu'il y a les élections qui
approchent c'est un moment très
important pour nous c'est une fenêtre
qui s'ouvre on a jusqu'à mai 2006 que tu
maintenant
que j'étais bouleversé par son courage
et son son mais vous êtes très courageux
aussi Renaud aucun courage si vous êtes
très Ardisson à deux semaines
d'intervalle
c'est courageux
Renault les Farcs les forces armées
révolutionnaires colombiennes la branche
armée du Parti communiste colombiens il
lutte contre la pauvreté il lutte contre
la corruption c'est des choses que vous
défendez normalement de poser ces
questions oui logiquement je soutiens
dans leur combat contre l'oppression
entre la misère contre
l'ignorance contre la malnutrition
contre le manque d'éducation le manque
de liberté dans leur pays comme je
soutiens toutes les listes de libération
des peuples les luttes armées c'est leur
méthode pour lutter pour leurs idées
utiliser le kidnapping de masse 3000
4000 200 otages aujourd'hui en Colombie
les derniers chiffres 30000 morts par an
les exactions quand ils arrivent dans
les villages qu'ils ont obligé à enrôler
les paysans de force dans leur premier
temps 3 dollars par jour ce qui nourrit
toute une famille de paysans quand ils
trafiquent la drogue ils sont
richissimes les dirigeants des Farcs
parce qu'ils sont et ceux qui font
partie des cartels de distribution de la
drogue dans le monde entier
je dénonce totalement ces méthodes qui
discréditent leur combat fut-il beau à
l'origine au départ
je vais faire une petite interview
chanson française Renaud
est-ce que comme Charles Aznavour vous
pensez que la misère est moins pénible
au soleil
partout soleil ou à l'ombre est-ce que
comme Jacques Brel vous pensez que les
bourgeois c'est comme les cochons
j'appelle bourgeois celui qui pense
salement disait je ne sais plus qui
est-ce que comme Georges Brassens vous
pensez que 95 fois sur 100 la femme
s'emmerde en [ __ ] par la mienne
est-ce que comme Édith Piaf vous
pourriez vous peindre en blonde si je
vous le demandais j'ai passé la moitié
de ma carrière tu as un blanc
le tournage est-ce que comme Léo Ferré
vous pensez qu'avec le temps oui tout
s'en va
non je pense que des idées qui restent
des sentiments qui restent des
convictions qui restent
est-ce que comme Gilbert Bécaud vous
diriez que l'important c'est la rose
elle est un peu fanée en France la rose
est-ce que comme Michel Polnareff vous
pensez qu'on ira tous ce paradis même
moi
on est les ordures qui méritent vraiment
pas le paradis ici s'il y a un paradis
j'espère qu'il est aussi un enfer pour
certaines crapule dans ce monde est-ce
que comédie Mitchell vous vous dites que
s'il n'en reste qu'un vous serez
celui-là j'espère que j'emmerde les gens
qui m'emmerde qui m'ont pourri et qui me
pourrissent ma vie qui font que l'homme
le plus heureux que je suis qui est la
santé le bonheur l'amour une famille
extraordinaire des amis un public le
plus merveilleux public de France
un métier qui me passionne et
et voilà ce le fait que ce bonheur
puisse pas être partagé par l'humanité
entière ça me pourrit mon bonheur ça me
pourrit ma vie ça me gâche ma vie et
tant qu'il y aura un chien malheureux
sur cette planète je serai pas je
pourrais jamais être le plus heureux du
monde donc j'en veux à ceux qui croient
ce malheur
vous dites bonjour bonjour les
hirondelles
et c'est comme Claude François si vous
aviez un marteau vous taperiez le jour
la nuit vous taperiez sur qui d'ailleurs
bah écoutez mon prochain album vous
verrez il y a quelqu'un il y en a
quelques-uns qui déroulent en fin de
plein plein plein
de votre partenaire et sur votre corps
lourd comme un cheval mort
est-ce que comme Dalida vous en avez
marre des paroles et paroles
je vis de ça moi j'aime la communication
l'expression j'aime l'écriture j'aime
les mots j'aime le langage j'aime le
dialogue j'aime la diplomatie c'est ça
je trouve c'est quelque chose de c'est
ce qui se différencie l'homme de
l'animal quoi c'est c'est extraordinaire
est-ce que comme Daniel Balavoine vous
vous demandez ce qui pourrait sauver
l'amour
et pourquoi il est pas en danger l'amour
tant qu'il y a des gens comme Mélanie
pour le porter comme ça dans leur coeur
pour leur mère et puis si je pense que
Mélanie c'est Ingrid n'était pas sa mère
elle serait engagée dans ce combat aussi
pour une femme anonyme depuis 3 ans et
demi prisonnière dans la jungle
j'en suis persuadé
vous avez envie que nous fassions
l'amour Renault avant de nous dire adieu
toi et moi non
essaie pour voir essaie
comme disait un ami à moi c'est bien
trop misogyne pour être homosexuel et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu